No,
I did not collect the tomes written for
one kind of high,
had relatively little to do with that
book.
That book was collected largely by
attorneys who volunteer their time to
work with people who were detained often
with minimal,
amazingly minimal,
uh,
legal process,
people who were detained at Guantanamo.
And,
uh,
I would assume with that,
knowing very little about it,
there's a tremendous range,
uh,
people,
range,
culturally range of a bunch shirt ranges
for people who are tremendously guilty
of many things.
The people who were really center,
many,
many things.
I'm the editor at the press.
It was about to publish that book.
Originally talked to me about writing an
introduction and uh,
they sent me the manuscript.
I tried conscientiously to read the
poems and uh,
I hope I correctly recognized my own
inadequacy.
I was not going to be able to write
introduction to these palms.
You would have to,
at the minimum,
you would have to know something about
Arabic poetry.
You would have to know a little bit
about these cultures.
And uh,
they come from cultures in which amateur
poetry is a very important component.
I'm familiar with amateur poetry,
this country.
I've taught adult classes.
I've taught in prisons.
Uh,
I don't say amateur with a sneer.
Um,
in many ways it's possible to idealize
the country in which there's a lot of
amateur poetry.
You know,
it might be good for professionals like
me.
Uh,
but I felt inadequate to writing the
introduction.
And at the same time,
uh,
I felt strongly about the abuses,
civil liberties and,
uh,
that,
military people were shocked.
Millet,
people in military people,
uh,
legal,
military people were appalled at what
was happening there.
And these guys who've just been a
tremendous fixed the pickle they were
in,
they'd been put in by the government of
my country.
I didn't want to just say,
oh,
I'm so sorry.
This is not my field.
So I tried to write a blurb,
um,
that would at least put my name in the
book and say,
this is an urgent book for us to be
aware of when you're thinking about
these people.
Uh,
they shouldn't just be sealed away.
and,
um,
apart from leasing from a government
that we don't work it as a part of Cuba.
Uh,
if you read that in facilities Hurghada
disputes,
I can't figure these people,
I don't know what,
what,
what's going on here.
Anyway,
there they are in this part of Cuba that
we lease from this government.
We refuse to have anything to do with
and uh,
we must have just forget about them.
Uh,
they need to be thought about.
And,
uh,
I was speaking because I had been
appealed to it.
We've very aware that my gifts and
knowledge,
uh,
whatever they are as a poet,
we're not terrifically Germane to the
content.
To that point.